There are mental illnesses that can't be fixed ... maybe,
without medicines
You know the medicine fixes the issue once, or twice ...
or three times.
And then all of a sudden on the fourth time or the fifth time ...
the ... medicine doesn't work any more
and the issue just gets worse, because ...
you know, they never addressed the problems in the first place, and so ...
They just get put on more medicine until
they're no longer ...
themselves [sigh]
"If you're one of the millions who experience anxiety"
"and your symptoms have lasted more than six months"
"it may be a sign of depression."
"It's a serious medical condition
that affects more than 20 million Americans
"Antidepressants help relieve the symptoms of depression
Narrator: Spring 2015, New York
Denis Mikhailov, a former office clerk from Manhattan
sets a new Guiness record for continuous running;
having covered 129 kilometres in 12 hours
Observers: "7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1" *Cheers*
We got the record guys!
Those are all, almost all,
different medications that I've been on
Narrator: This is Chris
Narrator: This is Josh
Narrator: And this is Debborah
Narrator: But our story starts with this guy
I was very lucky when I,
when I think I barely passed the English test
So I got accepted into business school
It was huge for a guy from a small town in Russia
– I didn't live in Moscow, or any large city at all –
to come to United States, completely different culture.
And, uh, for me it was eye opening experience
Because I learned about the world of finance ...
the way that the world works
The company that I was working for
they were doing what was called,
"Healthcare Communications".
Which in reality was
advertising for the huge pharmaceutical companies
Whenever they came up with a new drug, or have existing drug
they would come up some new ways
to advertise it all around the world
Ad narrator: "I don't want to live with depression"
"I want to enjoy life again"
"I feel this pain constantly"
"This guilt is always with me"
"Depression may be a result of a chemical imbalance in your brain
"Tell your doctor about your problems and ask for a prescription."
"There's no need for you to feel bad any more."
It's 10pm now on Friday
I'm looking at this building, on the 8th floor
Something tells me that my boss is still there
because usually Friday night
before heading home for the weekend
we have to wrap something up and, you know, another long day at work
Not really missing that part of it:
Staying in the office for 10 hours a day
Denis now has a new view of his former job
A few years ago his life changed drastically
And he has his reasons to help us make this film
[TV news in background]
This guy's name is Matt
[more TV news]
Today he leaves his parents' house to go surfing
It's his life
What you gotta do is just go down the hill and make a right.
Cameraman: OK.
Matt: And then we're right there
Cameraman: OK, we will catch you like in 10 minutes.
Matt: Yeah, come on
Matt:You can meet all the crew
Matt: Come on down
Matt: When I was, I think, 11 or 12 years old I was
put on a drug called Acutane
which ... was
an acne medicine that ...
blocked the ... vitamin D
So that your skin would be ... not as oily. I guess, I dunno
Unfortunately the by product of that drug ...
is that it caused, like, severe depression.
People who surrounded me in Russia while I was growing up
Nobody was taking any kind of drugs,
And here, I was surprised to hear, or see,
even young people taking some kind of pills
to improve mood or,
to get more energy. I wasn't sure what was going on.
And then when I got involved in this ... world of pharmaceuticals
I saw this huge array of different drugs, geared to different people
to treat different conditions. Most of which I'd never heard of before
I'll never forget where I'm like in a room
And it's all mirrors and I'm wearing this like ...
Red and black checquered hooded coat
And, you have to take these tests
sat at the metal desk, with the metal chair in the mirrored room
So you can't see anything but you in the room
And then they take the paper away
And the like observe your behaviour, post.
And like, obviously, if you have nothing to do and you're a 12 year old kid
you're gonna be like messing around with whatever, and so
And then they're like, "Yeah ...
"Well, based on his behavioural pattern ..."
"He has ADHD or ADD" or whatever
So they're like, "OK, let's put you on ... Ritalin."
Denis: I should be fair here,
We were coming up with really engaging and interesting advertising
so that we would really make you think about taking this product
Woman: Hello Ecuador from Times Square, we love you!
In a way it was a very creative work that the agencies were doing
I was doing only the financial part of it so I wasn't involved in the creative process
But I could see what was going on and I was, uh ...
I saw the final, the end product of the work that they were doing
Olivia: Here's the Vyvanse
What is that? Antibiotics.
What is this?
Oh here's the Seroquel
Concerta literally has the word "Amphetamine" in it
OK, these were all prescribed at the teenage children's hospital when he left
Olivia's mother: And it seems like when kids have problems in school, automatically the teacher wants to give them drugs
You know for years she wouldn't even do it.
You know and when she finally does it, it's like ...
Olivia: All hell breaks loose.
Yeah.
I had a lady today referring to the medication as "homework pills"
Mother: Homework?
Olivia: Homework "pills".
She said "We're gonna switch your homework pills to when you get home from school."
And that's the one he was on for just a week
because it literally made him into a zombie. It was crazy.
You know they always say that they want to reunify kids with their parents.
It's not their goal to keep the kids from their parents, but ...
When I worked in the children's system ...
They did everything they possible to make it hard
on the parents to get their kids back.
Like tonight, I had to drive an hour and a half just to see my son.
Denis I met somebody who I got  really close to on a personal level
And, uh, this person shared her story with me
Which was ... pretty dramatic
She um, she was taking ...
pretty hardcore psychotropic drugs, by prescription, since pretty early age
And she really got me engaged in this, uh, research
I never took it seriously before, because I didn't have any personal experience
But being with someone who, um ...
Who depends on those drugs. Who doesn't just know a lot about them, but physically depends on them
um, got me really involved.
Alright, no luck yet.
The struggle with addiction.
I did it for 40 years
I actually had to go to a rehab
I got kicked out after two weeks
And my wife and I were on the run for 6 months
We went turned ourselves in and got ourselves straight
And now we're doing good.
Took years to become an addict. Takes a long time to get rid of them.
So I just think that, like
that society is no longer trying to push
children and people to accept the problems
that they have inside themselves
That they're pushed to take this pill and it will all go away
[Wind chimes]
Amy: Right here he was fine
This was before; he was sitting with our second in his lap
This picture, yeah, he was fine
This is after
Um, about 2 years after. You can see his wrist is twisted in the picture.
This was last year at my brother's wedding
He was able to hold our youngest daughter for just a few minutes.
So you've go that picture. His wrists are twisted, that's the dystonia
And up here in this picture was last father's days, his wrist in that ...
He was able to hold our baby for a few minutes, for the picture
So when we watch TV, he paces behind the couch
Um, for a lot of the time
[Child protesting]
Narrator: This is Josh, his wife, Amy and their five children
So basically what I do on a daily basis is ...
I just pace. And I pace and I pace and I pace ...
And I don't ever get
relief from pacing, but ...
It's the only thing I can do. If I don't pace
and I sit
it makes everything a lot worse. And the pain inside ...
gets worse
my movements get worse when I have to
sit still or even stand still
so
pacing to me is pretty important. It's the only
it's the only thing I can do.
I started a new job
and I was feeling some anxiety, um ...
a little depressed
so
that's when I got on Effexor
And ...
a few days after that
is when I started feeling that inner pain
feeling that I had to get out of my own skin
[Dog yaps]
[Electronic Music]
Denis: So, my personal interest in seeing this doctor is that
A few years ago I fell in love with a person who
was addicted to psychotropic drugs
and Dr. Peter Breggin is one of the very few people
very few specialists who is a licensed psychiatrist
who has experience of almost 50 years
He never prescribes the psychotropic drugs to his clients
He's one of the very few people in the United States,
if not the world, who knows
how to do it correctly.
Most importantly, how to
break the addiction
without doing even greater damage to the person.
So I think we are all going to learn something very valuable today.
After we see this doctor in about 1 hour.
Um, we even got him, like, a hospital bed
Where he can
like, raise it up so he can have his legs in the air
Because that's how he comfortably slept
My mom didn't know how long you guys were going to be here ...
Cameraman: Indistinct question
That's ah, his name is Si. He's from a redneck type reality show.
Cameraman: [Indistinct]
Cameraman: Redneck reality show?
Olivia: [laughs] Yeah
Cameraman: Thank you
Olivia: Mm-hmm
[Crashing surf]
And so the parent naturally wants to go, like, "I wanna help my kid".
And then ...
The doctor's like, "I can help your kid. I can give them a pill." (Or her a pill.)
"And that pill's gonna make them happier"
And they're not actually making that kid understand anything
Other than, "rather than deal with who I am as a human being, and in my soul and in my spirit".
I'm gonna take this pill so that I don't have to
learn about myself
Chris: I was a, uh, I was a punk rocker. And, uh ...
I was a, what do you call it, a gutter punk and
basically lived on the streets
just doing whatever I wanted to do
Narrator: This is Chris. Once a heroin addict
He's now hooked on medication
He came to see us with his girlfriend, Irene
This is his parents house
The room that he lives in
and has to deal with his akathisia and everything ...
was so small that we couldn't fit two more people in ...
to film in there. That's how small of a place he lives in.
[car radio noise]
Erm
This pill, I have to take it every 8 hours. So 3 times a day.
Cameraman: And yellow one, what's the name of the yellow one?
Chris: Gabapentin.
Cameraman: White one?
Irene: Ativan, 2 milligram and a 0.5.
Feeling depressed? We have something that might help
Check with your doctor. Go to your doctor and ask for "ba", whatever the drug is...
One of the things we've become expert at is how they manipulate the results.
To make it so that, it doesn't look like there was much suicidality, for instance
Um ...
I always thought that people who killed themselves were weird
[cries]
But I can't live another day like this
And I almost killed myself last week.
[wind chimes]
[squeaky swings and sounds of children]
I find my self doing things and saying things that I don't mean
Um, It's almost like there's someone else living inside of me
like, controlling my body and my thoughts and the things I say
One of the documents that we got while we were working on some suicidal
behaviour drugs
for serotonin re-uptake inhibitors
One of their internal scientists, Roger Lane, said:
"It's not so much that they're committing suicide,
"their death is a welcome alternative"
"to how uncomfortable it is to go through akathisia"
That document does not get placed in
the medical journals. Doesn't get placed on TV.
Doesn't get placed in radio ads or ...
newspaper ads, or magazine ads.
But, that is a documented scientist
inside one of these major pharmaceutical companies
Saying that, "We have a problem here"
Concerta
Risperdol
Vyvance
Adderall
Hydroxyzine ... for anxiety
Zoloft
Reperdol
He was also given
Hydrocodone for pain and then Oxycodone for pain
And, um ...
Ativan, of course.
I was hoping that you guys came down earlier today
[Cameraman laughs]
So when I ...
got off the drug and ...
wanted to, like, give blood to ...
you know help people, or whatever, to not die [indistinct]
It's like you couldn't give blood
after taking Accutane for 6 years
After taking that drug
So that gives you an indication of how strong that drug is
6 years you couldn't give blood.
Because of what that does to your blood system
and like whatever, you know...
Sucks.
In next room: I'm leaving, you want me to take her?
Alright I'll leave Gail and I've got Sheri
A real therapy dog, huh?
Dr Breggin: I tell stories about my dogs
And the patients, especially children...
Dr Breggin: She's 13
Denis: Wow
She's a sweetheart
What do you think?
She  doesn't see much,
Doesn't hear much
But she smells really good, she'd smell that a mile away
We know from monkey studies
just how the amphetamines work, when we give them to children.
Give them to monkeys, the monkeys stop socialising,
they stop hugging and kissing,
they stop trying to escape from their cages.
They become good caged animals.
So we're making good caged children in our schools.
But the parents don't get this.
And he said, "I feel like I can't stop shuffling my feet"
It's hard to explain. It feels like, um ...
Like there's ...
Like I'm being persecuted, like, ah ...
Like I'm being tortured in a torture chamber
but it's happening inside of my body
So there's nowhere ... there's nowhere to run
I was always brought up to trust doctors
A lot of people say that, "Trust doctors, they know what they're doing"
Until you find out that they don't
And from there it's just a snowball effect
When you're hurt by something, a medication, especially
Doctors almost become ...
ah, defensive
When you're trying to tell them things like this
And their only answer is to try more drugs
and try more drugs
And it's just, it's scariness
And it's tiring.
If you don't go to your psychiatrist they get offended.
because they have feet of sand.
They're selling a false product
So they get very angry as a group
There are always exceptions, but as a group
they get angry
They might even lock you up
for wanting to come off your psychiatric drugs
But they do get paid, I mean
they do get paid per kid, per ...
household, whatever, so ...
I don't know how that all works, but
it's a system all in itself.
So who gets paid for it?
So, the poor, the disadvantaged, um ...
foster children, Medicaid pays for it.
That's a governmental agency
that pays for medications for
people who can't, children,
people who can't afford it.
Ah, older and people who are 65 and older,
Medicare pays for it.
Ah, military people, Tricare pays for it
Prisoners, our tax dollars pay for it.
If there is an avenue for a flow of income,
flow of money
To pay for the medication,
that's where there will be
ah, people prescribe these drugs
in a massive way
And they make so much money from it
that they are then able to
use that as part of campaigns with legislators
and with insurance companies
to see to it that they get even more
prescriptions done.
It's quite an operation
We were pregnant with
our fifth child when this happened
And he couldn't hold our newborn
because his hands are moving so much
Trying to live this way, um...
Like what she said, my kids ...
They on a daily basis,
my kids will ask me to play with them ...
Um [sighs]...
So many times where I have to
I have to say, "I can't play with you"
and it hurts
As a father that really hurts
I just can't believe it
I just can't believe that my life has taken this turn.
This is not how ...
I ever expected my life would be.
I always had plans in my head
for the kind of husband
and father I'd be, and ...
and it just
I feel like that's all been taken from me,
that's all been stolen from me
Barbara Ann, that's my wife of 30 years
and she had 3 strokes, passed away,
they brought her back
and now she's been in a rest home,
been there about 5 years
It's a 2003 powerstroke
With a 7.3 diesel in it
Wake up every morning,
have breakfast with my dad and all them,
So, you know, can't really ask
for much more than that
Just havin' fun and ...
just livin' the dream
There's four girls right here
young horses
Cameraman chuckles
Hi girls
This one's just a yearling
This one here is pregnant
She just arrived from Spain not too long ago
They're always ready
Doing the things every day that are kind of
repetitive but important,
like washing the dishes and you know.
Taking care of the horses is like that.
It takes a lot of dedication, and ...
You have to really self,
motivate yourself, to get up early in the morning
You know, do what needs to be done
Cos it's a lot of heavy work and ...
Moving 'em around, riding, exercise
You know, healthcare
But they just return so much, they just
give their hearts so completely to you
And I just get so much satisfaction out of it
OK, go ahead ... this top step is a little tall
So, you go ahead first, yah.
Sorry it's so small, but [inaudible]
[jumbled]
Debborah: My bedroom [laughs]
I realised she could detect my seizures
She could predict my seizures
So I got her certified as my service dog
And she traveled with me everywhere
for, like, 5 years.
And she would tell me, she would alert me
before I had a seizure
and i would have time to get with someone,
to sit down, you know, be somewhere safe
And so she's pretty amazing
But she's upset now because,
for over a year, she doesn't have a job
It was always more, never less.
They told me my akathisia was ...
"agitated depression"
That my depression was turning into bipolar
as they said was quite common
"Oh, just needs more meds, new meds"
All due to the fact that I was raped as a child
And never dealt with it.
It was always pushed back
And when my parents first put me on drugs
It was so ...
They were so relieved
See she's a problem
We don't have to do anything, it's not our fault.
She's crazy and all that.
So I finally got so fed up,
I decided myself that I would get off
Well, I found that it wasn't quite so easy
Sometimes we were desperate
Sometimes we just fell in despair because
we had the feeling that
maybe she would never feel like a human again
without the drugs
I mean, she was still developing, her brain was still developing, when she took her first psychtropic drugs.
She was a teenager and ...
we didn't know if it would be possible
for her to ever live without them
So it was really hard to find a specialist who would
help to move in that direction
But we did find some information
We learned about tapering. We learned about
the correct way of getting off these drugs
And basically it's the same as
getting off any kind of
street drugs, or smoking, or alcohol
the same idea
And so I basically lived my life
drugged out
I fought to do anything
It was either, too up, too down,
too this, too that ...
Those drugs are so horribly addictive
When I tried to get off them myself
It was an experience that I couldn't relay to anybody
You have to go slowly,
it's really important
if you've been on a psychiatric drug
especially multiple drugs,
for months or years
I've written a book about it.
It's called,
"Psychiatric Drug Withdrawal"
So, I found Peter Breggin's book
"Withdrawal from Psychiatric Medications"
and I followed it to a tee
I took all my 7 medications
I just shaved off a little piece of one every day
and it took me over a year
and I finally got off of everything
Cameraman: Is this from Star Wars?
Both:Yes!
Cameraman: Nice
This is a 2 milligram
And this is a half a milligram
And I take
So I take both of these 3 times a day
So, it's seven and a half milligrams
Um, and, uh...
By shaving it down
I've gotten down to about
[sighs]
Half a milligram
In ...
Maybe, 5 months
So
[voice cracking]
It's a very very long, slow process
And, um ...
And this is only one medication
I have ...
I have, uh ...
Two other medications to ...
Get off of
Some of the documents we have, it's like,
"Why is this important?" Like withdrawal
Some drugs, when you get on them it's
very difficult to get off them because
they change the architecture of the brain
When the drugs are taken away,
people think that their depression is returning
When actually, they're going through withdrawal
Just like you would if you were withdrawing from cocaine
or withdrawing from heroin
It's withdrawal
For,
these companies it was a big deal to not, um ...
some of these companies
to not have the withdrawal be a feature
in the labelling
We were really drawn to each other
on some emotional level.
It wasn't because of drugs that, um
that we were together
it was something
probably something deeper,
but ...
As with any addiction
Street drugs, or alcohol addiction,
or whatever addiction, gambling ...
any addiction makes a relationship really hard
and it took a huge toll on us.
So ...
We couldn't hold it together because of, uh ...
because of this, but ...
We did last for three years
And we, every single day
one way or another
this topic was coming out:
What do we do today
to make the addiction better?
To make the side ...
To make the withdrawal symptoms better.
To make her feel like a human again.
My bike I kind of
consider to be a
life saver in a way, um ...
The one thing I can do,
I'm comfortable doing
outside is getting on my bike
and riding it, um ...
It helps because on my bike I'm constantly pedalling
So I'm always ... moving.
My legs are always moving,
so it helps
I'm sitting but I'm moving
And I enjoy it. I can get out
and I can move a round
So, normally everything inside my body feels like
it's going a million miles an hour.
And I feel like I don't have any control over anything
in my life.
Nothing.
But when I get on my bike
I have control of my bike
You know, I feel like I have control of my bike
of something. The bike definitely helps a lot
And, I like to go at night,
because there's not a lot of people outside at night
And I can just be by myself
and not have to worry about running into people
That helps a lot too.
That takes a lot of the worry and the stress off
This is what horses do for me
Cameraman: Really nice
Camerman: Kind of a bodybuilder
Yeah, and that makes you feel good
And that kind of happened surprisingly
One day I'm like, "Oh!" And even in the back
I'm proud because I'm 61
And most of the women I know that are 61
You know, they're like couch potatoes
Cameraman: So you're looking at the waves yeah?
Yeah
[indistinguishable] ... and this is Topanga, right here.
[indistinguishable] ...
Cameraman: A lot of people
Obviously, If I wasn't ...
in the sea and wasn't participating in the ocean
I think you never get rid of it.
I think that that's the ...
that's the ...
thing that the parents ...
and society ...
and doctors, and psychologists, and things don't ...
maybe don't understand.
There are no lifetime studies
I mean one of the more recent approvals in the FDA
of a stimulant
for, so called, ADHD was 3 weeks long
So then you're gonna say give it for months
or years, or a lifetime?
And why are the studies only 3 months long?
They're all neurotoxins
So after a few weeks the patients get worse
So you can't carry the studies beyond a few weeks.
This is such a giant fraud.
I am just in shock that it continues on and on
All the research,
all the long term studies
– which are people like me –
There were no long term studies in the beginning
when those drugs were approved.
I'm the long term study
I was affected horribly by those drugs,
they never helped me
It was all a mistake.
I should have never been put on drugs
I should have been nurtured a little bit
by my parents
and not told
I'm a reject and I deserve what I got
and it was all my fault
And I'm just not like everybody else in the family;
defective
When those parents put those kids on the drugs
They're teaching those children that
there's something wrong with them
That's something that's instilled in there ...
and they will likely never get over that:
"They're defective"
They need a pill to fix them
You know every human being
on the earth has their issues
And children, when they go through trauma like that,
Huh, what do they need?
TLC, understanding, someone to take them by the hand
and tell them it wasn't their fault
"This is how you get through it, you be strong"
You don't just take a pill and forget about it
It's just ridiculous to me
It's laziness on the parents' part
And not enough concern to look into the facts
And see what happens to these kids
long term – it's not a good outcome
It's not a good outcome in any way
It never helps.
Chris' mom: How he was? Well ...
He was a very happy young, young child
And when he hit about 4 or 5
he started to become very rebellious, um ...
We tried to deal with it
the best way that we could
And when he hit about 4 or 5
And it just kind of
you know, the kind of ...
"You can't make me do this"
And anything we would say,
he would be argumentative about it.
Um ...
"You can't make me do this"
We spent a lot of time with him as a child
My husband and I worked opposite shifts
And so one of us was
almost always with him
Um ...
My husband and I worked opposite shifts
You know it just kind of
escalated as he got older
When he was about ...
in 4th grade he started having
a lot of trouble in school.
So we started seeing a psychologist
and ...
um ...
He would not talk
To the doctors
We tried to do family counselling
and things like that and he just, he wouldn't
He wouldn't talk
He said that we didn't love him
That was what he always told the doctors
That was his problem, that we didn't love him
That was his perception
That he was not loved
And he never did open up to the doctors
We did put him on Ritalin in 4th grade
For 1 year.
And we took him off.
And that 1 year he was having a lot of trouble
It seemed to help from our perspective
The next year we took him off
So he took it for, what, not even a year.
Probably 8 or 9 months
He didn't want to follow our rules, um ...
He was smoking and drinking
and experimenting with drugs
He didn't have a lot of friends
He didn't get good grades and he was
doing drugs and he wasn't responsible
So we didn't give him a lot of priveleges
And the other kids got a lot of priveleges
And that was another thing,
he saw just that and thought it was unfair
But they were always good students
and well behaved and, um ...
And like I said, saw what he missed out on
and were determined ...
not to go down that same road.
It was a good education for the other two
Yeah and I don't know. I honestly don't know what ...
created the issues that we had with him
No we don't.
Obviously we didn't do something
Cameraman: OK.
You know there's something missing in his life, from us
But, I can't see that ...
I can't see what we did
[Door slams]
There now see he's mad at what I just said. Something I said ...
set him off, just now
Where did you go?
Where are you?
set him off, just now
Where did you go?
I know, but where?
Which way?
I said OK
I know, but where?
Which way?
I said OK
There is hope, there's always hope.
and that's a relief for me.
To have control ...
I don't know, I'd be dead
Because the drugs don't work